ha terminado esta mañana el congreso del
partido comunista con la previsible
aprobación de las enmiendas que dan
todavía más poder así sin pinta me ha
servido para que fuera nombrados los 200
miembros del nuevo comité central que a
la vez mañana elegirán a los 25 del
polízburgo y a los siete del comité
permanente y con la lista del comité
central ya podemos adelantar algunos
puntos no estarán como la previsible dos
miembros que han superado ya la edad
oficiosa de jubilación pero tampoco
otros dos que no lo habían superado
hablamos del Primer Ministro lique Chan
y de One yang que precisamente sonaba
como su sustituto esas cuatro vacantes
dan un amplio margen de maniobras así
sin pin para que moldee el principal
órgano de gobierno y lo llene de
acólitos la imagen del Congreso había
llegado unos minutos antes de la
votación cuando un bedel pidió al ex
presidente a wishington sentado a la
izquierda de sí que se levantará y
abandonará la sala lo ha hecho
finalmente después de resistirse en una
escena que ha dado pábulo a todo tipo de
especulaciones quizá se debió a que Ju
se sintió indispuesto y que recordar que
tiene 79 años y que se había visto muy
desmejorado durante la semana O quizá
fue la escenificación de una purga sería
una maniobra inédita porque nunca se
había actuado contra un expresidente y
porque estas Este tipo de purgas exigen
de un proceso judicial previo menos
sorprendente ha sido que el partido
incluyera en la Constitución su
oposición a la independencia de Taiwán